aside from Bruce Lee Mike Tyson was my
idol you know I was looking at Mike
Tyson wow you know I mean imitate him in
fact how he moves I said well can I use
something that Mike Tyson moved in my
movies so when I realized oh he's gonna
be in Ant-Man three so I was both
excited at the same time a little bit a
little bit nervous I was like you know
what if he accidentally knocked me out
knocking me out is fine but
I gotta finish the movie right and I
told you and pink I said I'm not gonna
be exactly like how we shoot the
traditional way of kung fu movies where
we always Dodge at a very Split Second
I'm gonna move when I feel the teachers
whether it is I'm not going to wait
until his his fist is here you know I'm
gonna move I had more of a great time
working in that film talking to him then
that scene itself like we'll be between
shots and I would ask him questions I'm
a fan you know you got to remember so it
was a very memorable experience working
with Mike Tyson